be careful he MV because quite often the
people that people typically envy
project success and that everything's
great but actually behind the scenes are
they really great is life really as
gravy when they're back home quite often
it's not the case but we don't look into
the backstory behind these people
there's loads and loads of people in the
public eye who when they roll out on
stage when they roll out in the studio
in front of the lights and the TV
cameras they put they put on a face that
just exudes success but actually behind
the scenes they've got a crushing
horrible existence that they carefully
hide from everyone
we're talking about sin today although
all the sins how are you sinful today
you're feeling sinful ma'am I've been
pretty virtuous to be honest I mean
lockdown sort of stops people going out
and doing things that might get them in
trouble so I've been boringly
virtuous how sinful can you be during a
pandemic you know yeah if you take the
the drop in A&E visits it's just you
can't even hurt yourself if you stay
indoors put those little foam cups on
all the sharp edges in your house
exactly and you make sure that you take
the steps carefully that's it and
particularly during the period where the
DIY shops were closed it's like I mean
how's anyone gonna drop their finger off
in a bank holiday if they can't go and
buy a scalpel lime scouting limes for
mojitos that's how that's how you do it
um so talking about sin the science of
sin your new book science of sin why we
do the things we know we shouldn't so
why why do we do the things that we know
that we shouldn't okay with him
okay I mean it's just it's just look
it's a longer book than that it's you
know what I'm usually very wordy so I've
my new year's resolution is to be more
concise that was perhaps too concise now
you say the thing is humans are driven
by instincts amongst other things and
those instincts if you take the ones
that are covered by the seven deadly
sins the important thing to remember is
if you were to abolish any of those
seven things it would be curtains for
Humanity we need a modicum of all of the
seven deadly sins in order to function
properly as individuals as communities
it's just when any of those seven
categories of behavior go to excess that
they are at its core antisocial now I'm
not a religious person I spent a lot of
time sort of singing hymns at school
because both my primary and secondary
school would Church of England but I
didn't really believe a word of it I
just thought you know I was always more
inclined to sort of the scientific
approach let's look at the evidence if
there's evidence to support it you know
more evidence to support it then to
refute a hypothesis then you you know
you believe accordingly but with I don't
know there was so much stuff in the
Bible that was sort of clearly
outdated but I thought how can people
still buy into this like I realize it
gives people a lot of hope and it gives
them a sense of community but but the
the concepts of believing like a literal
interpretation of the Bible in a
post-enlightenment
time it just seemed bonkers but the more
I looked into it having sort of got my
PhD in neuroscience and scanned a lot of
brains and sort of got much clearer on
what we do and don't know in terms of
human knowledge
modern wisdom I realized that actually
there's an awful lot of stuff in those
ancient books of religion Bible and and
others which you shouldn't throw the
baby out with the bathwater just because
you thought for me personally just
because I don't believe in the
supernatural doesn't mean that there's
not something to be learned
you read between the lines and that and
that's what I was so correcting the
error of my ways it's so interesting I
got this quote from Donald Kingsbury
which hits the nail on the head there I
think tradition is a set of solutions
for which we have forgotten the problems
throw away the solution and you get the
problem back sometimes the problem has
mutated or disappeared often it is still
there as strong as it ever was
mm-hmm and that reminds me of a friend
of mine she's an amazing woman she's
like an engineer or in a designer and
she sort of designs healing spaces not
in a hippy way I'm talking about
psychiatric institutions build the
buildings and the park land the open air
so that it fosters healing rather than a
lot of you know let's say bedlam
hundreds of years ago it was the
opposite of a place that promoted
healing and after so she's doing a PhD
in Sweden four and a half years into a
five-year PhD she realized that all of
the answers had been reached by the
ancient Greeks
so if only she'd been a classicist and
read the right ancient Greek books all
of her what she thought was modern
discoveries using the latest
cutting-edge research techniques it was
already there it's just who's interested
in history we're all interested in the
future and what technology can be
bonkers days that is crazy is that The
Linde effect the fact that we always
presume that newer is better and
especially given the fact that so much
of our time is spent on Instagram
stories or faking stories or whatever
that is content which has been produced
within the last 24 hours
it's the guest lyndie platform like by
design but yeah so but also but also the
fact that when you're consuming
information so rapidly that you're not
really you're so eager to get on to the
next thing because it's more about
quantity than quality when you consume
social media you're not even focusing on
what you're saying let you get to the
end of the paragraph and you know what
another 10 paragraphs now screw it I've
got enough I'm gonna move on to the next
thing but it means it means everyone's
knowledge is superficial and rapid and
people don't bother to go deeper
and deeper to get a thorough a more
thorough understanding and by anyway we
can't fix the whole world know we what
we can explain to people about seven
deadly sins today so do what do we want
to do them is there some part of us that
wants to do these these capital vices
which is the other term that you have
you've got the seven deadly sins or
capital vices as you call them that why
aren't we the masters of our own
behavior why aren't we the masters of
our own behavior
pop is partly because finding the right
path in life is a balance like there's
always pros and cons there's always
pluses and minuses there's always
benefits and risks and each individual's
capacity to pick a path which finds that
Goldilocks zone that sweet spot where
you're doing everything in moderation
and you're not letting anything go to
the extreme it's different by everyone's
capacity to do that is well decision
making in general is driven by you don't
remember the last hundred times you made
a similar decision but honest or
subconscious basis there's a trace of
whether it works out well or badly when
you went for the risky option that that
promised a high return compared to the
low risk option that promised a low
return and so quite often finding that
balance between
sort of giving that urge for immediate
gratification a little bit of airtime
but not too much and an on average
always trying to go for what's best in
the long run you can't do both
yeah like quite officer let's say that
the best example I think is gluttony
right because gluttony gluttony is
overeating over drinking greed is just
wanting more of anything no matter how
much you've got already
and that gluttony thing was an absolute
design feature back in you know hundreds
of hundreds of thousands of years of
human history if when food was available
he stuffed your face and built up fatty
deposits it meant that when the
inevitable lean times came where food
was unavailable for weeks and weeks and
months and months you know this Scrabble
for existence was tough we're very
pampered in this day and age under
conditions of prevailing food scarcity
you want to get fat in the harvest time
so that you can survive through the
winter right and so it's actually a
logical thing to do to fit to shove
everything in your face and
instinctively we love like first release
carbs sugary bread EK key stuff we love
fatty stuff of course we do but we're
not designed to eat every day our
metabolism can't cope with eating that
stuff every day and then you've got the
forces of advertising saying hey don't
buy all that expensive kind of
nutritious food it's much more
affordable let's appeal to the
cost-effectiveness to get a family bill
you know get get a bucket of fried
chicken get you know get in the habit
get in train in the habit of eating
takeaways or
sort of microwave meals every single day
without fail now a little bit of that
stuff is fine but there in everyday
screws you up so the instinct to over
eat used to save lives in that people
could live for long enough to reach
sexual maturity to have sex with someone
pass their genes on to the next
generation like by hook or by crook
every single one of your listeners you
and me we have an unbroken chain of
ancestors who managed to live for long
enough
to reach sexual maturity and shag and
have a baby it's astonishing
without that propensity to overeat that
wouldn't have happened yeah
so those humans who didn't have that
propensity to overeat they didn't live
but you know that their ancestral line
petered out nowhere else at the point is
when you fast forward to 2020 the
environment is now defined by food
overabundance in the vast majority of
places in the work in the developed
world at least you know the shops have
even even in strange kinds of social
isolation that the shops do run out but
that there is plenty of food available
you know so no one's there's very few
people starving to death in the UK right
now right and and so that means that
that whole gluttony urge is now a design
flaw we're battling against it in order
to sort of stay in relatively good shape
don't you okay so how do you define the
deadly sins they are well maybe since
they are perfectly natural human urges
which in extreme cause absolute havoc in
one's social relations it makes you
vastly unpopular with other people if
you take more than your fair share greed
if you don't you know pull your weight
you know in a collective endeavor that
you know teamwork kind of thing we can
get so much more done as a team than we
can individually but one person shirking
their duties then they become very
unpopular
you know lust causes all sorts of have
it in that people end up having
relationships outside of the person that
they might have dedicated you know their
their life to and then once people feel
betrayed it's very hard for them to
trust again and you go through every
single one in moderation we need a bit
of lust otherwise you don't pass on your
on your genes we need a bit of greed so
that when if you if you've accumulated a
bit of an excess then when you hit tough
times you can injure them more easily
every single one of those things it's
like in moderation it helps us but in in
excess it makes people push us away it
makes it people think you know I don't
want to hang out with that person
anymore because there's so
aggressive you know the drop of a hat
they're kicking off and I just don't
want to be around it anymore and what
the point I just want to quickly get to
is social isolation is they're literally
deadly these seven deadly sins because
if you're socially isolated you die
earlier and whilst you're alive you have
a higher higher incidence of things like
depression anxiety disorder personality
problem personality disorders so so you
die of cancers and cardiovascular
disease to a much earlier if you're
lonely it's an all have all cause
mortality risk isn't it loneliness yes
and that this has been my since nineteen
eighty eight right
something was you know we mentioned this
earlier that a lot we're sort of if we'd
only look more keenly at what was
already written down we wouldn't have to
I wouldn't have to look at all of the
fMRI brain imaging data to figure out
what makes people do these things you
know I could just well I'm glad but I
went through that process because for me
personally I'm benefiting hugely from
having a clearer understanding of the
role at the seven deadly sins play in my
old own life as an atheist and I pay
much more attention to them now having
written that book and by making sure
those seven behaviors don't go to
extreme I'm not falling out with my
friends and family and co-workers you
know to the same degree as if I was
oblivious to it all I just carried on
being selfishly narcissistic I kept
taking treble extra servings and leaving
other people with not enough to eat you
know but I am quite a greedy gluttonous
person and it's made me think
differently about it it's so interesting
when you see this the ancient wisdom
then get re shown in modern science man
like it it's so funny it just reminds us
how highly we hold ourselves in regard
and modern science and modern wisdom you
know we will hold that obviously the
podcast fantastic but the you know the
actual in itself and then you realize
you totally correct like just read a bit
of Seneca like Seneca or in Epictetus
add that sort it out mate or whatever it
might be so what I find really
interesting about the seven deadly sins
in the way that you put it together was
that you said it's common categories of
human behavior that caused people to
fall out
and what that suggests is that if you
were like an island if it was just Chris
or Jack and you went through you some of
these sins that it wouldn't cause as
much of a problem but when there's other
people around that increased friction
the work between you and those around
you that it kind of magnifies the
problem is that I'm totally with you I
think that's a very reasonable thing to
say the one thing one caveat is no man
is an island and I think what we don't
realize is the degree to which friends
aren't just nice to have they are
absolutely essential to our well-being
and that's not about having 500 you know
friends on social media you can have one
or two really reliable mates that you
can talk things over with like the human
brain generates lots of hypotheses lots
of potential explanations for why things
are happening some of those notions
absolutely start raving bonkers and you
need your mates and your family members
are the people around you to reflect
back on whether the parts of what you're
saying them add up and make sense in
their objective view and the parts of
what you're saying that they're just
flying the sky
you know bonkers and that's what people
who are socially isolated don't have
that and they end up doing their head in
with getting hung up on some of those
notions that go round and round in their
head
confirmation bias they've got no one to
sort of push back and and and and say no
no no I did I disagree with that but
that's the most useful thing someone can
do it when when they honestly say to you
I disagree completely for the following
reasons because it makes you aware of a
different perspective that we simply
it's very hard to have multiple
perspectives when you're looking at the
same pair of eyes or listening through
the same pair of ears each day so those
other people in your life help you to go
through all of your notions and beliefs
and sort of what hopefully so long as
you're not in an echo chamber of people
think the same thing and give you a bit
more balance and it's the same thing
with this modern wisdom ancient wisdom
there's a lot of nonsense written in the
ancient wisdom the nice thing about
looking at it from the context of modern
science is
helps you to separate the wheat from the
chaff you know it helps you focus in on
those pearls of wisdom that were bang on
the money where is likely Plato thought
that the brain was just sort of you know
they thought that all the Spirit was in
the heart and the brain was just the
radiator for losing heat you know they
might have been good at philosophy but
they got their Anatomy yeah they needed
to do a little bit of work on that
didn't they so what I'm saying it's like
we can't just rely on ancient wisdom but
but looking at it through the lens of
modern science I think you can start you
know working out what bits to focus on
and and and really put your weight
behind and what bits just just it's just
to let go ignore it but I worry about
people who worry about the fate of their
life sorry fate of their soul in the
afterlife because there's a lot of
people who you know like the Catholic
guilt thing people beat themselves up
people are hard on themselves because
the expectations of certain people in
society in the society that they're
they're raised in hold them to such like
high standards impossibly high standards
like the concepts of being able to steer
clear of the seven deadly sins your
whole life is is poppycock because that
they are driven by fundamental basic
human instincts like you know they're
related to the very fundamental
instincts that are evolved in the drive
for survival so some people are going to
do well at being disciplined some people
going to be bad at being disciplined but
I would argue those people who are
overly discipline are missing out on
life that they're postponing everything
for the afterlife which may or may not
exist so why not just make a heaven of
life on earth it's a very good argument
man I don't know I mean increasingly as
I get exposed to books like yours and
more evolutionary psychology and as I
start to wrap my head around how we
operate and why we are the way we are
the concept of who but what is natural
to us seems to become more and more both
clear and muddy at the same time mmm
does that make sense like you don't when
you start to strip away ego and
predisposition and you're the way that
you've dealt with your trauma and your
the genetic heritage and all this sort
of stuff when you start to strip that
way that what I hang on how much of this
do I do before I'm no longer me but how
much of that do I need to get rid of to
be more of me
and again the Senecas got this concept
which is called the virtuous mean and
it's not a vice of excess nor a vice of
too little yep whatever undid like not
enough I didn't I was that middle
section a little bit right that's what
we were kind of touching on today so
that's let's get into them pride first
thing pride isn't pride a good thing I
won't have pride I'd done some well
shouldn't I should be proud of yourself
yes you should be why is it why is it
why is pride of sin it's confusing isn't
it you should take more pride in your
work how many times we told that at
school so the positive side of pride is
it's a natural human emotion kicks in
during childhood and it rewards an
infant feels proud of themselves when
they do what mommy or daddy tell them to
do and then when they get positive
feedback and they get smiles and claps
and you know like body language and
vocalizations that make the kid realize
that they've done good they beam with
pride because it's reinforcing when when
the world tells you that what you've
done is good in moderation it's good
because it makes you more likely to
repeat that positive behavior but the
trouble with pride is when you take it
to excess you end up with essentially
narcissism that the sin of pride what
what the ancient religious thinkers
thought was negative bad about people
who are overly prideful is almost
indistinguishable from what science and
medicine these days thinks of as
narcissism so it's things like feeling
like you don't need other people you're
completely self efficacious all about me
me me me me I don't need anyone else
being very vain thinking that you're
better than other people are pretty much
everything even in the sort of face of
stark evidence of the contrary you just
you just can't you can't believe that
you're not just brilliant at everything
so the average narcissistic person is
the kind of person that
really gonna rub other people up the
wrong way like they're always throwing
attention to themselves
and a lot of narcissism seems to be to
do with poor self-esteem and that can
either come from neglectful parenting or
overly attentive helicopter parenting
both of which can lead to what what
psychologists describers an
undifferentiated sense of self like so
their sense of self doesn't develop
properly early on in life which means
they don't really know where if you take
the helicopter parenting example the kid
doesn't know where they end and their
parents begin there's no dividing line
they just because they have their
parents views force them and the whole
time they don't know what they think
they just mimic parrot fashion what the
parent would say in all situations and
carry on doing that through life so
those kind of narcissists need to work
on that to sort of basically stand on
their own two feet
ego wise if you like and and and
although they seem nice they seem like
they're so full of themselves they're
constantly looking for reassurance
positive feedback from the rest of the
world which is why they're such a
nightmare to be around like anyone who
does something good oh I'll take I'll
take responsibility for that I'll get
all the praise even though it wasn't my
idea but I'd convinced myself it was my
idea so now all the praise should be
showered in my direction and then if you
don't give them that praise they get
really aggressive if they get really
wound up and they're just a social
nightmare so narcissistic people almost
always end up alone even those in
relationships they choose relationships
which are basically yes men yes women to
constantly give that positive
reinforcement and that's not really a
relationship relationships involve
give-and-take so there's still an island
even when they're in relationships so
narcissism is is is the queen of all the
deadly sins as far as sin Gregory the
Great was concerned and and he's the guy
who basically invented the concept of
the seven deadly sins
he took something that there were so
many sins before his time in the sixth
century that it was hard to keep track
of all the things you shouldn't do
but he said narrowed it down to look
these are the seven most important
things to keep your eye on you know
there are lots of other things that are
gonna prevent you from going to heaven
in his view of the world but I think he
was bang on the money to sort of refine
the list down to a more easily
manageable seven because then we've got
a fighting chance of remembering them
what are our capacity to cold
information in mind is limited to around
about seven items so expecting someone
particularly you know hundreds of years
ago thousand years ago to Rick to bear
in mind when they're considering should
I shouldn't I do this thing ten
different like commandment it can't even
read or write but they've got 45
different commandments they've got to
try and remember but say with the ten by
the time you get for the eighth
commandment you've forgotten what the
first is a Christianity we just had
expectations that go beyond the limits
of the brains capability so I think I
think it's in Gregory smashed it by
bringing it down to seven why did he say
Queen what's that mean probably because
he's a massive sexist and I think the
idea was and I'm unjust I'm presuming
that it was along the lines if he could
have said the king but because Queens
you know from the perspective of a
religious man who had you know devout
he's married to God he doesn't do women
women are the temptress is who make men
think about lust you know lust this one
I said I thought you said pride was the
Queen Prize so the idea is that once
pride has seduced you you will be much
more likely to full fowl of the all of
the deadly sin o maiden greed including
gluttony it's that pride to by unity
on-ramp it's there's the it's the
gateway the Gateway Vikes that leads to
all the other so those I mean whether or
not he was right in that regard I don't
know but that the most interesting
finding from the neuroscience stuff was
actually to do with scanning the brains
of people who are high in narcissism in
an fMRI in an MRI scanner and then
compare their brain responses to social
rejection to those who are low on the
narcissism scale and a part of the brain
that lit up
more strongly was a brain area involved
in in creating our perception of pain
whether it's physical pain or
psychological anguish this brain area
which is called the dACC it's a bit of a
mouth for the dorsal anterior cingulate
cortex love it hmm so it's like it's
where the two halves of the brain meet
in the middle just above and to the
front of the band of neurons that
connect the left and right side of the
brain this big bundle called the corpus
callosum it's jet it's just a patch of
brain tissue but it's a little bit above
an in front of that particular structure
dACC and yeah and that that brain so
basically what what does that mean what
that means is when an artistic person is
socially rejected they feel the pain of
that social rejection more acutely and
so what I took from that is perhaps that
explains why there's such dreadful
people in a social in a social circle
nuts that they're incredibly touchy
they're very easily offended you may say
any amount of offense that someone in
the group in their neighborhood in their
family might cause them you know one
unit of intended offense causes ten
units of of pain which presumably they
will then ruminate about and plot their
revenge you know aggression and envy and
wrath two of the deadly sins I'm sure
we'll try about later that they often
inspire thoughts of plotting for revenge
you know getting your retribution for
what normally boils down to hurt crime
yeah that's interesting I mean everyone
that's listening knows or has a friend
there's someone in the circle they might
not be in it anymore
who makes everything about them it's Jay
from me Inbetweeners you know it's just
the epitome of the guy that yeah yeah
yeah but I did this yeah yeah yeah but I
did that Carroll all the way it's fixed
mindset human what you know picked the
avatar that you want to talk about this
but um yeah I
I feel for these people man like that
people that excess pride and a super
narcissists like it makes me feel bad
because I can watch their programming at
play and that's not to say I'm [ __ ]
immune I watched my own programming at
play as well and I feel bad for myself
which is like a whole second circle of
hell that you can descend into but you
watch these people do it and I'm like
[ __ ] man like a you're you're a cool
girl or guy you don't need to do all
this you don't have to have the show I
I'm perfectly happy being out at dinner
with you or going to the gym with you or
doing or whatever without this whole
game you know you just preempted
absolutely beautifully the conclusion of
the entire book which is that that's the
best way to deal with these people
bit of compassion you know talking about
the ancient wisdom but has been banging
on about that forever you know two and a
half thousand years but it Buddhist
teachings that suffering is inevitable
and that the best way you can deal with
people in the world all creatures or
anything in the world is to be
compassionate you know to think of to be
more mindful of other people's suffering
so it doesn't matter which of the seven
deadly sins you're talking about I found
evidence for that brain area involved in
generating psychological anguish in a
turmoil it's it's it's on a hair-trigger
in four out of the seven deadly sins and
probably in the other three to the
relevant neuroscience studies haven't
yet been done like any neuroscientist
who wrote a sort of a a request for
funding for research he said yeah I'm
gonna study the seven deadly sins they'd
be laughed out of the room right I got
lucky that there was enough neuroscience
to work with to try and estimate what
these brain areas do but but you there's
bang on the money I thought I got the
end of writing the book and I thought
well what can people do with this
knowledge like it like is that is how
can it guide them on how to live a
better life and I've got a nice little
anecdote about how I actually failed to
put it into practice myself decided the
best way to deal with people who are
falling foul of letting the seven deadly
sin type behaviors go to the extreme and
causing social chaos
everywhere they go best way to deal with
them is to be more mindful just to think
about how much extra inner turmoil
they're dealing with than the average
punter and I when I finish writing the
book I went back to the place where I
was inspired to write the book which is
speakers corner in Hyde Park you know
for us Brits it's this and in fact in
the world it's the home of freedom of
speech and and it's been that way since
1186 and and it was sort of put into law
in the 19th century because back in the
day when people were going to be hung
from the neck for some kind of crime
they'd get a chance to say a few words
they're going to be dead in a few
minutes that you know doesn't really
matter what they say and I love that in
Britain we had this tradition of letting
people who were doomed say their piece
it seems like a very reasonable thing to
do anyway so I used to go down there a
lot
I'm born and bred London I love
rollerskating one of the best places to
roller skate in the whole of London is
up and down by the serpentine and when I
got tired all the way through my teens
and twenties I just go around to
speakers corner and have a little listen
to all these usually man up on their
ladders preaching away about whatever
they wanted it was invariably about
religion
I remember thinking it's such a shame
that all these people like that like I
love that they are permanently preaching
their beliefs and a lot of them errant
beliefs in my view but they had a place
where they could speak their beliefs and
there's something very liberating about
having the freedom to express yourself
even if you're completely wrong and I
thought it's just a shame that science
doesn't get a look in and it was there
where I where I'd sort of listen to them
argue well 10% of what you said was bang
on the money and I can learn from that
but 90% was supernatural poppycock you
know it was mostly people arguing over
whose religion is best there's quite a
lot of people from one faith having
arguments with people from other faiths
you know stress this thing and going
around around a circus but anyway I went
back there and I got up on my own
soapbox and I preached from my own book
and I sort of I said I thought people
would be interested you know passes by
oh you want to hear about the scientific
perspective on the seven deadly sins and
and it's up on YouTube if you go to sigh
of simcom I made these little videos
I've got a friend to film it and there's
a little six minutes
of the hour two hour long talk reggae
now about 20 minutes from the end this
is like 11:30 on a Sunday this bloke
just came to wander over like a bottle
of cider in his hand absolutely hammered
homeless guy just shouting abuse at me
non-stop for 20 minutes and I think I
had to deal with him like I blanked him
for five minutes that didn't work
I brought mince the conversation a
little bit trying to sort of use him to
make some points that didn't work he was
just drunk and belligerent anyway I'm
not proud
I edited it out so there's no but it was
of it but I gave him a piece of my mind
I was rude to him I got angry I let him
get to me and in front of a crowd of
about 50 people
I said if he quite unkind things which
didn't help matters but nothing else had
worked fast forward for months I went
back to the same spot I gave the talk
again except you can't just do it once
and I told the story of how I had failed
to be compassionate with that man and I
was slightly embarrassed that I didn't
put my own you know dude I basically did
do as I say not as I do
and I thought if I get the chance I'd
like I'd love to make a mint you won't
believe it
10 minutes from the end of that tour I
saw him coming over from the background
I saw him wandering towards I left off
my soapbox I ran over to him and I was
like so great to see you again I'm
really sorry for what I said last I
threw my arms around and we gave him a
hug now this guy is you know a lot of
homeless people I'm mentally ill is a
very high proportion it like I did it on
instinct as it felt like the right thing
to do obviously on unplanned and at that
moment of embrace him I thought is he is
he gonna stab me like you know I could
end up getting hurt here what an idiot
on the contrary he melted
he was tense and then when he like I
held him for about 510 seconds and I
felt him relax into my arms which is
weird right and he was good as gold but
for the whole rest at all he did not
disturb once whereas before we go you're
not an every neurologist you're a lady
you know he was good as though at the
end he came up to me as I actually
listened to you this time and I come
down here to disturb these people so I
think
religious zealots and nuts and they
shouldn't be telling people to follow
God I think everyone should make their
own decisions in life and that's why I
come and be disruptive he's like now
that I've listened to you I agree with
every word you said man which was nice
which was nice what a cool story so
having been on the front door of more
nightclubs than I can remember
I know the pain of dealing with someone
who's drunk and when when people have
got alcohol in the man there's just no
sense you're not talking to them you're
talking to the blood alcohol point 100
or whatever it is that's what you're
talking to right yeah but yeah
definitely what I really enjoy doing and
I'm enjoying and doing it increasingly
now is breaking the fourth wall of a
conversation in that sort of a manner so
if someone's doing something if someone
is being driven by their programming or
they have a response to something I'll
ask them about the response not about
what they said but like hang on a second
man like why why did you say that or why
why were you so sort of self effacing
they're like why did you have to kind of
caveat what you were gonna say and say
that oh well I know that it's just [ __ ]
but it's this thing it's like why didn't
you just say it oh well uh huh huh and
you can see people the cognitive
dissonance starts to fire and you're
like the programming just it doesn't
want to accept the fact I should have
just said the words but increasingly I
think you know doing it with compassion
not doing it to show off doing it to say
look like you don't need to be over or
under you that kind of fool the virtuous
mean in the middle is exactly where you
can be and I think calling people out on
that it's as you said at the beginning
you want to be friends with people that
want the best for you not people that
tell you what you want to hear people
that decide to be too mean and kind of
use you as a punching bag for their own
kind of emotional challenges but man
that's it that's a really really cool
sorry I'm super glad as well that you
managed to get some closure and and and
kind of finish that loop off because I
imagine it must have felt very very
satisfying also obviously because I ate
away at me I pride myself on not
hypocrite I tried to not be a hippie and
not being a dick I'm gonna guess as well
yeah well I try yeah and what that kind
of thing it does you know that there are
other things that like I mentioned one
in the book about Roth where this this
guy I got I was doing some filming in
Brighton and I got the end of the line
and I was I was actually writing society
since then you know I was researching
and writing and I had my papers over it
took ages to tidy everything up and then
the train conductor but went through the
carriage said you got to get off and I
was like yeah yeah and I was hurrying to
get my stuff but you know I I was
basically dithering and he locked me in
the carriage and then I went up to the
next carriage that one was locked too he
had me running halfway up the length of
the Train before I could actually get
off and I'm like me we do and you saw me
there I went absolutely mental at him so
you know the homeless guy that guy you
know literally enraged like my blood
alcohol level was super high and I felt
like my pride was wounded but I spent
weeks like I just kept popping into my
head examining and why did you react
like that why did you do that and I
think that's one thing that this sort of
new modern wisdom inspired pursuit of
light let's use all this psychology
research and this better understanding
of why we do the things we do to try and
make ourselves better I think I think
one of the main things that offers us is
the opportunity to not be so hard on
ourselves and what I liked about your
anecdote is it sounded like you give
reflections to people that helped them
catch when they're going into set-piece
behaviors where they kind of either
beating himself up too much about
something that they did or writing off
their potential to potentially be better
because it's easier if you don't try you
can't fail you know and I think a lot of
people who are a little bit stuck in
their ways from an objective perspective
it's like they're worried about trying
to be different because if they try
something new and it doesn't work then
that could end up giving their
self-esteem a bit of kicking bro I love
I love trying to bring people up like
that there's some people that as far as
I'm concerned it just lost causes and
that's more from a time efficiency
perspective
there's certain people I know that have
excess pride and I'm just dude like
you're you might you might figure it out
you might not figure it out maybe you
stumble down the right YouTube rabbit
hole I'll start reading the right books
and maybe you don't but it's this isn't
Wi-Fi I'm leaving you to it but it'll
say you're not quite a bit with respect
you're not qualified to I'm not
qualified to show you that the only
people who can really help those people
are ones who can go you know trained
better than all of the psychologists in
there let's go back to and work out
where all this came from because it's
like I guess if I'd imagine what my
mum's a therapist so I've got some
insight into what the process involves
not that I've ever gone through it
myself
which is one of my long lasting
hypocrisy because I know I should do it
but I still haven't yet got around to it
yeah it's it's it's working out what
life experiences led you to certain
set-piece behaviors that aren't good for
you or other people because it's not a
sort of zero-sum game well-being and
Happiness like we can all together lift
ourselves it's not like one person's
happiness detracts from your own envy
wise if someone else seems really happy
it can emphasize your own relative lack
of happiness so so quite often people
don't want to be around perpetually
cheerful people for that reason but
ultimately you need professionals to
help you understand why you just keep
doing things that rub people up the
wrong way
neuroscientists can't really help you
well-intentioned podcasters but you know
like if you did the course I'm sure
you'd be brilliant because you have I
would argue on the basis of what you've
shown so far in the last 40 minutes
you've got it man like you've got enough
of an overview of what makes people tick
probably from all the time you spent on
the door dealing with every different
type of person under the Sun but you've
got that life wisdom that means that
once you had the I mean maybe your
psyche there's I don't know but if if
you don't have that training if you've
got that knowledge that official
training on top of your life experience
you'd literally you know train change
people those lost causes would be found
again make that that's a long journey
who am I to say initial so I'm good
friends with Charlotte Fox Webber
the head of psychotherapy for the School
of Life in London and I had her on the
podcast and she was telling me
psychotherapists need to have five years
of consistent sessions on themself not
that they give it it's like that that's
like saying yeah you as a PT you're not
allowed to be fat and also you've got to
be really fit before you can be a PT I
thought I thought that was really really
cool look my mum blew me away when she
said every it's impossible to be an
effective counsellor if you don't have
counselling yourself oh yeah because
your own neuroses come out in the way
that you're trying to be objective but
they set pieces that your unconscious
plays on you will end up interfering
with your ability to help them I love
that terminology I've never heard it
before set-piece behavior yeah since I'm
thinking autopilot autopilot babe it
makes me think is what happens with a
set piece in a sport right is that first
the guy runs this way then this person
goes out then the ball comes in then
this guy goes back across then this is
going to happen and it's the fact that
it happens this kind of iterative like
staccato game of it's like first this
then that afterwards this and then it
finishes up here and sometimes it might
go well and sometimes it might go bad
and that's what set pieces and that's
what happens when you see people who are
part of this the Animus possessed you
know they're just part of that
programming as it goes let's look let's
get back we have six sins remaining
gluttony gluttony is up next and we
touched on it earlier on right fitness
enhancing we have it's the only time in
all of our human evolutionary history
where we were outside and get us a 99
flake now I'll pause the but know that
guy because literally I think I know I
must sound like such a dick yeah but
like whenever whenever they come past I
think you're just there to make fat
teenagers fatter I don't like mine so
mine goes past the end of my I don't
like mine because he always
when I'm recording content and it's
always on the take where I've nailed it
and I've had the auto key running for
ages and then it's the war and then
Lacey's got the just one Cornetto music
because for a couple years he had some
god-awful nursery rhyme so you know we
got to be grateful for the little stuff
of nightmares
so yeah gluttony fitness enhancing for a
long time we were in a situation where
food was scarce we didn't know when the
next meal was coming now the world's
changed and we're in this abundant
surplus of food but apparently if we
still if we eat too much of it
it's a vice why because it's really
really bad for you if you're say there's
been some quite interesting research
done with looking at the white matter
integrity so the white matter in the
brain is like the the neuronal cabling
you know like there's billions and
billions of wired brain wires sending
electrical information from one end to
the other reaches a synapse
spills a bit bit of neurotransmitter
into the gap travels across to the next
neuron in the chain and then that one
becomes a little bit more or less likely
to send its own electrical messages so
it's got this the reason its white
matter rather than the gray matter is
because there's a go-faster rapper
called myelin around the outside to
accelerate the speed of that electrical
message so that it can get where it
needs to go super super fast so when you
talk about the integrity of the white
matter it's basically how good is that
go faster rapper is it is it in good
shape or is it in bad shape and if you
look at the brains of people who are
obese as far as their BMI scan concerned
and you compare them to the brains of
people who are lean as far as BMI is
concerned if your average 50 year old if
you're obese the white matter looks like
what you'd get for your average lean 60
something-year-old you know so it ages
the brain by 10 years there's lots all
sorts of kind of cognitive capacities
that are reduced so this is obviously
it's not vice from the
to heaven or hell we're getting away
from that entirely a vice in terms of
making a hell of your life on earth
compared to what it could be you know I
had the greatest sympathy for people who
struggle not to overeat because I
overeat hugely I love it it's subtle
I've always been a sports person and and
since childhood I had tremendous
excessive energy and that wasn't my
choice
in fact it caused my parents pick like I
never stopped I was constantly running
around climbing up things I wanted to do
every sport that was available on the
planet I just wouldn't stop so all I've
done is continue doing that even though
I keep up the same level of sport I've
still found that I have to constantly
focus on eating less increasing the gaps
between my eating so that I don't end up
you know eating something just for a bit
and then eating as soon as I get up in
the morning I'm trying to extend that
period where I'm fasting and and it's so
it's a constant battle and it's weirdly
only now they said it because I can't go
to the gym I can't do anything else it's
only now by doing and we go back to the
hypocrisy thing again I was a little bit
overweight BMI wise and it's only doing
10k twice a week instead of doing 10k
once a month and my normal like playing
gym on football once a week where I've
lost 4 kilos and I've got down into that
healthy BMI for the first time in about
15 20 years so I'm not I'm not a fat
basher because if I had a different
metabolism if no if I had an injury that
prevented me from doing sufficient I
struggle to regulate my eating in you
know like as as much as the next person
but the consequences if you do allow
yourself to become obese in terms of
your brain health are pretty serious
throw the quality of your life depends
upon the quality of your thoughts as far
as I'm concerned as the quality of my
thoughts have improved the quality of my
life has improved linearly actually no
it probably increased exponentially it's
probably that my life has got better by
a factor of how much better my thoughts
have got um Tom MacGregor from social
chain said to me and I first have a
podcast he's a big sobriety advocate as
a my elective sobriety just for
people that one more time and money in
calories to spend on [ __ ] they care
about and he was like bro everything in
your body is made from the stuff that
you put in your mouth everything I was
like yeah hang on a [ __ ] sec you're
right
I can't I can't build anything in my
body if I don't first put it on a plate
or in a rope wrapper or whatever and
then put it in me and I look back I look
back to me at uni and I think what was
what was i eating at uni like wake up
big bowl of Cheerios last night domino
Domino's Pizza go a lecture to come back
Budweiser
Budweiser a bit of pasta probably
something go out vodka you know what he
said I'm glad I'm glad you're mentioning
the booze here because the word gluttony
comes from the Latin glassier which
means to gulp so it's two over caspase
see it's not just food people folk
buttony they always think food food food
mates it's drink - and a goodness of
consumption then yeah it's just so long
as it goes in through your mouth yeah
it's it's it's gluttony and and it's
really important to remember the huge
amount of sugar that is in you know your
average can of lager or glass of wine
not so much vodka but the stuff you mix
the vodka with usually very very high in
sugar and that's that you know those
invisible calories we don't really count
those calories because it's like it's my
god-given the God that I don't believe
in my god-given right to be stress with
a glass of this which turns into a
bottle you know and because it can so
easily slide from a glass of wine a day
into a bottle if you're if you've got a
big mouth like me and it takes what you
have to notice that one glass is turned
into two and a regular basis before you
can rein it in I dearly don't let it go
that like when you see this life happen
if you don't buy it in the shop then it
can't be on your self detect you can't
eat your revolver in the cupboard man
yeah it's the easiest way to not break
your diet okay look round is in the shop
it is if you bring it in through the
threshold of your front door it will get
it's gonna be consumed yeah one form or
another you'll snort it or put it up
your Bhama do something with it
Rocky Maivia [ __ ] was getting our hand
next one
lust which was my personally in the book
that was the chapter that I found the
most interesting it was also the wooden
I can imagine triggered people the most
and was the most uncomfortable well I
want if you would I want you to first
off actually do people have conscious
control over what makes them feel
sexually excited no absolutely not
no one should feel guilty for feeling
sexual desire towards another person
because we have zero control over that
whether or not we act upon that
temptation whether or not we act upon
that attraction is a whole different
matter but the actual you know we cut a
gay man can't control whether his lust
is triggered by looking at a man or a
woman a straight man cannot decide to be
straight or bi or gay it's just it's
just not it's not we do not control we
have no conscious control over what
makes us feel sexually excited which is
what I guess looking back at the ancient
way that the church dealt with
homosexuality makes that a very
pernicious way for people to have to
live your sod amis anything that isn't
having sex with the intent of making a
baby okay so and any sexual activity
that isn't aimed at making a baby is
sodomy in the eyes of Christianity at
least the original you know back in the
days of Christ that would include the
withdrawal method
well well-timed withdrawal method yeah
yeah and masturbation and all sorts of
things which everyone is a very innocent
everyone that's listening is a sodomite
yep very much if you're not a sodomite
if you're listening and you're not a
sodomite I want to I want to meet you
because you interesting but that's even
in the context of this even in the
context if you're going to be really
strict about it and then let's not bash
religious perspectives because that you
know there are different there are
different interpretations of this is
that this is the original guidance back
in the day that inspired the concept
to lust being a said one of the seven
deadly sins right like this is this is
the antecedents to this belief we're all
around that but even that would be even
in the context of a married couple you
know married in a church if they have
sex just for fun that's sodomy like if
you have sex with a condom on that
sodomy well it's bonkers yeah it is so
can you take us through the burns and
Swerdlow tumor study
can you write me what that is there were
a lot of study so it's the why it was
the one about the married man who was
having sexual Peter Phillips sexual
urges yes so he's a guy who was to all
intents and purposes a responsible man
he was a teacher he you know held down
jobs well he was liked by you know not
the most popular bloke him in the school
but he was you know stand-up member of
society he started developing sexual
urges towards his stepdaughter his
stepdaughter mentioned this to her
mother and who was 14 he was 14 quite
rightly that had a word you know and
with with the law and he got banged up
for pedophilia because he'd made
advances on his stepdaughter he then
complained of a banging headache and
whilst whilst incarcerated and so they
Julie took him for a brain scan found a
massive Channah tumor pressing on a part
of his brain and they removed the tumor
he then plain said that all of his
pedophilic fantasies have disappeared in
no longer wish that he could still have
his you know like when he was in prison
he still was hankering for his
collection of pedophilic material he was
going to have the the nurses as well or
like the assistants that were in the
recovery facility he was in as well like
do where anyone that he was going to
make an advance at right yeah yeah and
then because they believed that the
removal of this tumor had removed his
pedophilic tendencies so the idea was it
was like disinhibition like I think
people who have those urges it's not
when it's not that the urges went away
it's his ability to to suppress them his
ability to do right by the law and do
right by not harming other people but
then once the tumor grew back when he
was out of prison
the pedophilic tendencies came back
presumably because he lost his capacity
to resist those urges and then he ended
up back in prison again so the reason
it's a really fascinating case is
because
it's so rare to have a case where the
the pedophilic tendencies were switch on
an awful bull according to the presence
or absence of a tumor that's why it's
fascinating dude it that study blew me
away reminded me I can't remember the
particular gentleman's name but the guy
who was in the bell tower that was
shooting people shot his family shot
himself and then said you need to do an
autopsy on my brain found out was a huge
tumor pressing on the area of the brain
which is to do with aggression and he
just felt this like unrelenting
aggression but even that man like we
don't have conscious control over what
makes us feel sexually excited we do
have conscious control over whether or
not we act on those urges that's that's
what we've got but that yeah that brings
up there's a big section in the book
about a pedophilia which I think is a
fascinating topic in ever since I was
seeing a girl at uni and one of her
housemates went to go and give a talk
lecture theatre saying that we need to
treat people with pedophilia with more
compassion because do you think that
these people want to be attracted to
children given the choice of all of the
different things that they could be
attracted to in the world do you think
they want to be attracted to children
ever since then I've I've been but stuff
like this absolutely fascinates me the
thought I do we think about if
philosophically how do we see it
societally you know well let's think of
it from the perspective what's best for
society right we want to reduce as much
as possible the incidence of pedophiles
making advances of on children because
obviously that scars children the rest
of their lives and it causes huge huge
problems so what's it what's a pragmatic
way of dealing with that problem it's
certainly not to make them feel vilified
so the minute they accept it everyone in
their life turns away from them when
they fake it were to go to a doctor you
know that they would they would worry
probably quite rightly that they might
get reported to the police because I'd
imagine I don't know for sure that your
average GP has has a duty or might
fearly duty to report this because that
person even if they say I'm controlling
it but these urges are there well do you
really want to take the risk that
they're saying one thing and doing
another of course not so but the thing
if you or I were a pedophile where would
we go for help and that's the bit that I
think we need to focus on if there's no
one to turn to where do you go
you hide it you suppress it is that a
good way to deal with problems
invariably no you know if you bottle it
and pretend it's not there it's likely
to grow you know you can get worse and
worse you need help but what where can
these people go for help so I think
what's happened over the course of you
know all time until now because they say
vilified they're considered evil wrong
broken beyond redemption and they know
full well that the only people who are
going to they're going to get a
sympathetic ear from our other
pedophiles and so then it's gonna go
from entertaining thoughts - oh [ __ ]
have you checked out this website
catalyzes the situation oh I can get
hold of some videos and you know VHS
videos or DVDs or whatever and then and
then it circulates and then it goes
underground and that's the bit that
concerns me society's quite
understandable attitude of disgust
towards pedophiles only serves to drive
them underground and it's such a hard
problem to deal with I think most people
just like they probably don't think
about it and so it comes up in the news
again but I think we need to address it
it's just who's going to do it like I I
certainly thought twice about putting I
thought it was important to include that
information but on a number of occasions
I thought maybe I'm gonna take it out so
I don't wanna sound like an apologist
that's absolutely why I'm not but at the
same time you've got to discuss it
because it happens in the world and you
know there's that there's a proportion
of people who have those sentences and
pretty much all of them in the UK as far
as I know don't have anywhere to turn to
get help to get therapy to get be taught
the tools of how to deal with it in a
way that doesn't ruin their quality of
life or that of anyone else's I think
you said there's a coal line special
yeah all line that's 50% of the calls
are unanswered gee the coal line not
being sufficiently well manned and I'm
like I don't know man like I'd be
interested the people that are listening
I'd be really interested to hear what
you think like
I am or comment below or whatever cuz um
it's a really fascinating topic and you
know anyone that wants to say oh this is
making this is an apologist thing for
Peter fight like [ __ ] off man like you
don't know what you're talking about
this has got nothing to do with that
it's to do with how can we have an
effective society which helps to bring
everybody along with it and at what
point do you make someone culpable for
the thoughts that are in their head like
you're actually going to make someone
culpable not only for thought crime but
for thought crime that by definition in
neuroscience they do not have conscious
control over yeah wishes and the able is
a [ __ ] she some of your listeners
won't have read it right almost by
definition and and the bit that really
made me think differently about it is
this thing called a plethysmography one
of the hardest posts of pronouncing
silent so again MOG Rafi
so you basically put a collar around the
base of the penis and so you're
measuring whether or not the person gets
an erection right it's completely
objective measure of sexual arousal
there's a similar thing in women called
photo plethysmography which measures the
lubrication of the pitcher essentially
when female genitalia become aroused it
lubricates when male weight changes
shape somewhat and lubricates and in the
mail it you know the penis becomes
turgid so you can put the rod inside the
hole is you know biological and simple
but especially so what I'm what I'm
talking about is the the sexual arousal
thing is something that we have no
control over and in some of these
studies that came out of a lab in Canada
the interesting thing was in order to
make sure they had a population of
purely pedophilic people they and then
they compared them against purely non
pedophilic people because obviously some
people they'll be overlap they showed
both parties children porn and adult
porn and the pedophiles got no response
from an adult pornography whether it was
gay or straight or anything else they
exclusively got a sexual response from
the pedophilic content which is why
they're included and vice versa
they had to make sure that those who
were turned on by
you know adult consenting we hope
pornography and the the you know they
weren't also a little bit turned on by
the pedophiles in order to make sure
that you really are comparing apples and
oranges that you are you know you're
getting the populations purely
pedophilic and purely non pedophilic and
so the fact that they bothered to do
that is is quite interesting in and of
itself but the fact that these people
are capable of becoming sexually aroused
to anything other than children it's
like you won't you wouldn't wish that on
your worst enemy Raman it's and that's
the thing as well especially when you
roll the clock back and you realize that
for a very very long time as soon as a
girl was fertile she would be pregnant
in fact his disease American is even a
term for the period between her first
period and when she becomes fertile I
can't remember the word for it but
there's a medieval term for that period
because it was so commonly used by the
waiting male for this why I don't know
what thirteen fourteen probably for most
girls when they start puberty I don't
know yeah I mean Game of Thrones there
you go Daenerys but you get my point
right two more things to my things in
lust I really I really thought was cool
um I didn't realize that the female
orgasm has a reproductive function well
is it the cilia is it called yeah hair
like hair like extensions that reach out
into the fallopian she left it actually
wafts the sperm into the correct you
know there's two fallopian tubes and it
wafts it into the one that the egg will
be found in yeah over and above the one
that didn't produce a I've is that
selective from an evolutionary sense
sure I mean I don't see how else it
could have occurred yeah okay cool so
woman enjoys sex someone that she has a
emotional and physical connection with
equals more likely to orgasm equals more
likely to direct the sperm through this
Mexican wave of little cilia cilia
things
down I mean that even just learning that
bro like the fact that conversely do you
wanna know a bit that I didn't put him
but you know the male male foreskin does
in certain practical physical terms act
as a little helmet and it's one of its
functions that it does the job well
whether it was designed for that purpose
or not is is you know very difficult to
discern but it it extracts the previous
deposit of semen so that your semen
makes it to the finish line no I thought
that was is that not to do with the like
the coronal head shape of the penis
itself that creates a suction inside of
the vagina is that not how that works
I don't think okay I think I think like
that but then in order for it to in
order for it to humping apart
okay so it's kind of it's catching it as
it goes oh dude that's so disgusting but
it's funny isn't it like if if that's
true and I don't know for sure whether
it's true I've just read some papers
that suggest I've heard it yeah
but I'm you know the concept of us being
historically biologically monogamous is
slightly dubious if y'all were the only
mammals on the planet but the only
mammals on the planet if that's the case
final thing final bit in lust Fidel
Castro had sex with 35,000 women bro
yeah that's slightly shocking if that's
not lust
that a control lust that's properly out
of control probably linked in with a lot
of pride probably linked in with a lot
of envy a lot of Rafi agreed absolutely
I don't I think I'd to go off on a
tangent of sin bundles like it you know
men who aren't happy with having two or
three kids but in some cultures you know
they'll have they'll have twenty thirty
kids with multiple wives it's like why
why why did you need to do this like it
that's not just lust that's that guy
that goes way beyond lust like you said
it is greed it's pride so many other
things
envy like the desire to cause envy and
others hmm yeah which is in itself of a
kind of a way of pride as well isn't it
yeah dude it's so interesting how these
all how these all interplay I think kind
of to to footnote the the lust category
it's one of the most binary categories I
think here that because of the way that
typical relationships are formatted like
there's not really a line when you say
that someone's being greedy and not
being greedy right it's like Oh believe
you crude this much wealth
there's your greed threshold yeah over
that bracket your active or you you you
ate this much food but you're not
allowed to eat this much food you're
officially a glutton or have it I think
I think if they were a threshold it's if
your excess leaves others without a hard
thing to measure it's a lot less hard
than you cheated on your partner yeah or
you had sex with thirty five thousand
women yeah that's like Fidel it's been
two thousand five hundred women let's
leave it there let's just let's call it
a day may are you not time so many
people have blamed their profligacy on
sex addiction but sex addiction isn't
even acknowledged by the psychiatric
world I think it will become don't know
I mean well it's all about whether
there's sufficient evidence to support
it if that evidence comes along then
if not no I'll never make it into it
become but it's funny isn't it the
people bandy it around left forearm of a
sex addict that is all yeah he's just a
coupe which he or she is complete sex
addict it's like but it's not a thing
it's just it's just it's not yet but
then depression depression wasn't
categorized as a an official mental
health disorder I don't think until only
fairly recently mmm not employed today
yeah true
okay so Envy next you say Envy is the
least fun of all vices what makes Envy
different to the other ones yeah well I
mean when you feel envious it's
unpleasant isn't it but when you snap at
someone who's doing your head in Roth
it's quite fleetingly satisfying even if
you might regret it in the long run you
know if you win at poker and you end up
winning all the money and the other 11
people or whatever around the table
don't get it that's fleetingly
satisfying and so the next time you go
back to play poker lose it all again so
Envy is you know there's as benign Envy
which is good which is where what do you
you compare yourself to other people
usually it's people who had a similar
start in life that this works with like
grew up in a similar part of the world
similar level of Education similar
opportunity similar start in life yet
one person the other person has gone way
beyond you and it can make you feel you
can respond to that in different ways on
benign Envy is where you examine them
you work out what did they do that I
didn't and you learn from them and you
work out gaps in your sort of toolkit of
ways to manage your life and deal with
the world and you may be you know think
you I'm gonna I'm gonna learn how to do
that or I'm gonna start moving in more
influential circles so that I can maybe
get some of those trappings to you know
we Envy helps us realize when we're
lagging behind other people in our
social group and we're not getting as
much as they are so it can alert us to
possibilities to potential the dark side
of envy is malicious Envy because there
are two ways you can even the gap out
you can either pull yourself up by your
bootstraps in order to get to a similar
level to the person you're envious of
but there's also the other way of
circulating malicious gossip and
bringing them tumbling down right so
quite often people respond to their
feelings perfectly natural feelings of
envy by wanting to bring about the
downfall of that other person by any
means necessary so the envy can inspire
awful behaviors incredibly antisocial
behavior in some people in some
circumstances I love do the way that you
put it you said Envy has a sense of
injustice at its core it's a really nice
isn't it why they got all this and I've
got nothing why are they there why are
they you know it's a sealed refrain
isn't it
a little bit is no it just envy being
useful motivating you to compete make
sense it also makes sense from a
evolutionary a fitness enhancing
perspective right you think like oh well
this is this is my get up and go and so
much of this is in its your own ability
to take yourself out of yourself and see
someone that's doing really really well
or even not see someone who's doing
badly but kind of just slowly creeping
up on you and I'm not seeing it as a
threat not seeing it as a zero-sum game
yeah the interesting about MB is it's
one of the one of the four where that
that brain area the ACC that's involved
in pain and at the moment people feel
Envy when they read about someone else
from their childhood doing really really
well much much better than them that
brain area kicks in hard at that moment
you feel mV you know it's sort of in a
turmoil is what is what inspires a lot
of unpleasant behaviors you know that's
that that's often the first link in the
chain that leads to unpleasant
antisocial behaviors which I I was
shocked that I kept finding this brain
area because I have to admit I when I
set out out on this project I hadn't
done I hadn't done the research before I
wrote the book proposal I found out what
I found
and then I reflected on it and then and
then wrote a book about it so I couldn't
believe how lucky I was getting four out
of five and actually gluttony was one of
the ones that this brain area didn't
kick up in Alaska how would that have
operated would that be when you are
going to have the food and you don't
have the food and you feel pain yes it's
when you're you're trying what funnily
enough I can't remember the exact study
but a couple of months after the book
was published a study did come out
suggesting the people that have problems
with overeating the at the moment they
make that choice to give in to it
it's almost like that the emotional
turmoil of the self-loathing about gone
here I go again my resolve is crumbling
from memory this was a year ago
but I remember thinking oh if only I'd
delayed by another six months when it
would have been then it would have been
six out of seven but I had to discount
lust the dACC was the might like across
the so many studies done showing people
porn in an fMRI brain imaging tubes and
the dACC comes up again and again and
again and again and again but I had to
discount it because it's also brain area
that deals in all sorts of conflict and
if there's one thing that you're told
over and over again in the MRI Qi it's
don't move don't move don't move and I
think that produces huge conflict when
under normal circumstances when people
are watching porn they do move a certain
part of their body you catch my drift
yes that they're not be able to touch
yourself when you're watching porn might
be the thing that was causing the ACC
not the porn in and of itself these that
so pain of having to withhold you hands
from touching yourself yeah which isn't
really that's not the CA time isolate it
right yes actually now I'm reflecting on
it again you could say that that's
involved in the urge of doing something
you know you shouldn't it's just in the
case of doing for the lady watching you
in an fMRI machine that's definitely
something that you know I shouldn't I
met I met this guy at the Society for
Neuroscience conference about ten years
ago who did some of the early fMRI
studies it is in Groningen in the
Netherlands and he said it was really
really hard to get radiographers to come
and support that research because they
thought it was founded a bit Bertie and
seedy so in the early days it was really
hard to get because in the in that
context he wasn't trained people porn he
was getting couples to come in and do
sexy time you know one person stays
really really still and their partner
would manipulate them in the scan and
bring them to ejaculation that has to be
a very challenging situation you got one
person I mean anyone that's ever been in
an MRI machine like yeah it's not it's
hardly the most sort of seductive it's
not like the candles and the Barry White
um aren't quite playing are they no
but and I guess okay so we understand it
we understand that envy is this
comparison mechanism that's going on I
guess that's got to be exacerbated in a
world where social media shows us a shop
window into the best of everybody's
lives
correct be careful he MV because quite
often the people that the others that
people typically envy
project success and that everything's
great
behind the scenes are they really great
you know his life really is gravy when
they're back home as when they're on the
sofa on telly you know quite often it's
not the case but we don't look into the
backstory behind these people
there's loads and loads of people in the
public eye who when they when they when
they roll out on stage when they roll
out on in front in the studio in front
of the lights and the TV cameras they
put their cut on a face that just exudes
success but actually behind the scenes
they've got a crushing horrible
existence that they carefully hide from
everyone it's not all it's not that it's
not the case of everyone but it just
seems such a horrible sound that people
are like consumed with envy wishing they
could have the trappings of let's say
this reality TV star who's just you know
got on all gone from nothing to having
an awesome life seemingly
if actually behind the scenes they wish
none of it happened because they were
happier before the bro I mean you won't
know I'm guessing based on the world
that you come from and the sort of
content you consume but I was on I was
the first person through the doors of
season 1 of love Island so I've no way
and I've done take me out up into
fernando's I've seen paddy McGuinness
all that full work so I'm full bluetick
wanker right I've seen both sides of
this fence and I couldn't agree more
some of the most miserable least
fulfilled least actualized people that I
know have the most followers and there's
this video that me and Dean video guy
Dean will finish very soon it's based
around this in a vowel rather can't
quote right and it says you cannot take
part of someone's life you have to take
the whole we look at people and we
presume that we can pick apart certain
elements certain characteristics of
either their life or their success or
their makeup and have them piecemeal
you don't get to have it piecemeal this
isn't a [ __ ] buffet this is all or
nothing look at Elon Musk and you think
he's so successful he's got this amazing
work ethic he's like PayPal mafia
billionaires super [ __ ] genius Tony
Stark guy but you don't know what Elon
Musk relationship with his body's like
what he thinks when he looks at himself
in the mirror you don't know the
thoughts that go through
head when he when he hits a pillow on
the nighttime for three hours this night
you don't know if he can't ever speak to
his father because he's destroyed his
relationship with his father it's like
what is the price of being Elon Musk
like are you prepared to pay that price
don't be Elon Musk and I think you're
bang on the mind a lot of the time man
III don't think that people are and this
is be careful who you envy is a lovely
way to phrase it man and you know the
fact I rephrase it because it's like you
can't help when the m/v kicks in it's a
bit like low well you can't you like you
either feel envious so you don't you
don't summon it it just comes right it's
a it's a natural emotion it's but it's
one of one of the natural human emotions
but once it has arisen I think it's
important to evaluate whether or not
that person is worthy of your Envy do
you not I mean like I don't want people
to feel oh god I've got to stop envying
that mate from school is really rich and
that mate from schools go on awesome
relationship and it's constantly posting
brilliant stuff on social media like
like don't beat yourself up for feeling
the envy but examine the likely cause of
that envy and compare that to the
realities like do some research find out
is it like I remember being blown away
when one of my female friends says oh I
always know where my friends are having
a crisis in their relationships because
they post amazing photos of look where
my husband took me look at the wonderful
meal look at the incredible view but
like I always knew there was something
funny about that but I didn't realize
that some people use it as a diagnostic
tool to work out when to pick up the
phone and Haley is everything okay I've
seen a lot of cupola photos over the
past couple of weeks and I was like oh
my god that's incredible reverse
psychology like that's brilliant that's
clever it blew me away
because I remember thinking when I see
that stuff I always think why do you
need to do that like I also find myself
doing something awesome thinking oh
maybe I'll take a photo of this and put
something up on social media for the
first time in 3 months and I think maybe
what I want to make other people feel
envious of the like one month in the
last three years when I've done someone
whatever what I've looked cool yes
but the bizarre thing if that is the
envy
causing envy inducing envy and other
people is a signalling technique that
allows you to reaffirm your position in
the dominance hierarchy right I don't
unfortunately you need to play the game
I keep on talking about this all the
time like I love conversations like this
doing my podcast I absolutely adore it
but I would keep the thirst trap in the
[ __ ] out of people on my Instagram for
as long as I've got abs and a jawline
I'm gonna keep on doing that because I'm
gonna play the game and if if that is
slightly less virtuous it's out okay but
that there's only so much that you can
hate the player
right like these are the rules that have
been set and if the end result is that I
gain X number of thousand followers per
year which I can then drive to a project
which I absolutely yeah in order to
realize greater greater benefits in the
long run I hope some short-term nasty
behavior for long-term good may well but
then maybe I'm just [ __ ] pulse talking
the [ __ ] out of it and I'm just what you
mean and I I've probably gone the other
way by not playing the game I've
probably under sold myself like my worst
nightmare when I started presenting TV
so I've presented half a dozen shows
over a decade
BBC Sky Discovery Science TLC even this
and stuff on MTV look I've done loads
and loads of stuff but my absolute worst
nightmare was a really hope I don't
become like recognizable in the street
because I enjoy my privacy and I and
I've seen the pain in celebrities eyes
when people come up on us and foster I
said oh god here we go again I can't go
anywhere without being bothered by
people like that's my worst nightmare
but I'm not playing the game a little
bit and not trying to raise my profile
it's got to the point where the BBC
don't call me to present the brain stuff
they call Michael Mosley and they call
the vent all kin twins I think they're
all great but I am NOT getting the calls
no I know game I've made my peace with
it because I write books and I present
no conferences or at least they did pre
covert you know I was doing
I felt I didn't need the fame but by not
playing the game because I'm trying to
be like ridiculously virtuous I've
probably sold myself short I haven't got
as far as I could be so I'm absolutely
not judging you and I didn't mean it
when I said he not things in the short
term to achieve great things in long run
it was just shorthand I know I get it
man but I used this example all the time
I've never had someone come out with one
of my club nights and say hey man I was
on the verge of despair I was having
this existential crisis I feel alone I
feel lost and then when I went in and I
had one of those one-pound Jager bombs
and heard those banging tunes man you
know you're just really tourmalet I've
never had that but I get that now like
three five times a day
a dear from someone that says bro this
and I've got this big gallery of air
like a folder on my eye photos that's
like every message I've ever received
it's like hundreds of messages now right
back to in a bit years but the fact that
like if that's the price that I have to
pay right if I need to pay a little bit
of discomfort of perhaps being more
transparent in order to then create a
platform for that to happen and the
thing is and this is something that
might be interesting for you to consider
is like if by you doing that people come
to you and they come up to you and they
want your autograph or they want to get
a photo with you but they say Jack man I
really want to find out a little bit
more about that burns and mud loss study
about the guy that did that to me like
when someone says dude I'm watching
episode 34 from the 10th of May 2018 and
in it some guy watched the second and
third episode back-to-back while he was
painting his house the other day and
asked why the camera was in the same
position but we changed t-shirts did we
film it in the same night and I was like
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] like dude that's so
cool that you watched both of the
episodes and realized that I'd got
everyone to take a change of clothes but
I didn't move the camera or the lamp so
that you rumbled the fact that I got two
episodes out of one sitting and like
that's really fulfilling to me like I
love the fact that you have like people
that care about
what you do you know some I don't know
man like the thing is so I don't the MV
was pricked when you mentioned that you
get I was anticipating you say yeah I
get I get three or five days a week
because I was extrapolating from my one
a month if I'm lucky but my point is and
it's I always try and think of it in
order to not think oh why don't more
people say this for every one person
that bothers to say something nice about
how one of my books really spoke to them
and they felt a benefit for theirs 909
my people who thought it didn't bother
didn't do a set what dude you you
absolutely correct like the this silent
listeners and this again is something
I've been throwing this terminology
around since the start of the year gasps
your friends up and it's like just
something I saw and what it really made
me think like there's so many times that
my mates do cool stuff I'm fortunate
that I have a circle of people that just
make amazing cool things and um there's
so many times that I see them do cool
[ __ ] and for a long time I wouldn't I
just wouldn't reach out not that I was
envious not that I just you know path of
least resistance like you don't message
them and now I use that as a trigger and
it's such a good habit to get into a few
things actually firstly if you ever miss
your friends the second that you think
about missing them text them text them
and tell them hey man hey man oh um I've
been thinking about you yeah you know
like I've been thinking about you do
that hope that you're good or like if
someone releases something and you watch
half of the YouTube video and you see
that they've invited you to like then
you miss this bro love that you're doing
the new business like real good good
luck that I'm super excited to see what
happens like the more that you drill
that and if you can make it almost
instinctive like they must some of my
mates must [ __ ] hate me because I'm
just like I've sudden not needy but
overbearingly supportive in in touch yet
at times but I I love it it really
really fulfills me and this is why I
think people reaching out to the content
creators it's the virtuous good side of
social media that you have a direct
channel between you and the people that
make this yeah yeah we consuming right
and I say that have other people too
what you can and can't do in terms of
your content you get freedom to do what
you feel is the right thing to do which
i think is huge and that's what I love
about podcasting and youtubing but
anyone can do it if they're inspired to
follow in your footsteps they can they
might not end up with your level of
success but I always say you know that
there's a lovely German phrase which is
a delve egg is that seal the sorry to
any German speaks out a terrible
pronunciation but it means the journey
is the destination
meaning you get you can get huge amounts
of implicit reward sorry intrinsic
reward as opposed to extrinsic reward
from the process of doing something that
you enjoy you've said a number of times
how much you enjoy doing this podcast
and it just gives you like you're giving
a lot you're giving a platform for other
people like me to say the stuff that
they're excited about but it's the way
you described it suggests that you get
implicit pleasure from having these
interactions and enlightening getting
feedback from your listeners and so
forth so but the point is it doesn't
even matter if you're successful in your
endeavor if you enjoy the process of
doing the endeavor that hugely promotes
your well-being so I am I am the proud
owner of a YouTube channel that I
present like every week I do something
and I get less than I get ten twelve
fourteen viewers leave my own show notes
below go and subscribe to Jack's channel
now link will be in the show go and go
and hassle him on his next manveer
please someone watch it but I don't
really my mates are like why'd you do
this and and I'm like because I just
really love doing it in a way I don't
really care like it might be that two or
three years down the line people like oh
look here's someone who's not eighteen
reviewing VR games that could be cool
and it might be that there's always the
promise that it might become a success
later but I learn so much from one month
to the next of doing these weekly things
like they used to last an hour that's
bonkers now they're half an hour
episodes you know I used to review
multiple games in one sit I now do one
at a time and I'm and I reckon when I
get to the Year point I'm gonna take
them all down re-edit them so they don't
look so bloody awful and the same
footage will suddenly potentially get
some traction but the point is pursuing
your hobbies hobbies are great because
they never end
like if you finally complete one
painting you can start the next one if
you master one instrument there's always
more music to learn or more instruments
to learn like that's the stuff that we
get happiness from a satisfaction and
well-being but it seems so normal and
average and boring like hobbies so
unexcited but it's tremendously
satisfying
to pursue multiple hobbies because the
whole point is you're not trying to get
anywhere apart from forwards no one
talks about them anymore you know know
what like you don't get asked the
question what are your hobbies like what
do you do is your hobbies it's what do
you do
Gary V's hustle and grind mentality have
you got your case Wis with the words
tattooed on the bottom of them on like
all that all that stuff like did you
only sleep for hours last night all that
[ __ ] like I do die doing things for
the sheer enjoyment of them speaking as
someone who only did things for
commercial gain for a decade all I was
bothered about was the success of the
business and making money and being
well-regarded in a world of people who
are all drunk and just after just have
to live Island man so I went on to live
Island and spent my time I had a
borderline existential crisis just after
and during love Island and it didn't
manifest on TV no one will be able to
see what was going on
basically I spent my time around a bunch
of people that were really the persona
that I had been pretending to be for 10
years and I was delivered a fatal dose
of contrast between the person I thought
I was and people who truly are that and
I realized holy [ __ ] [ __ ] like that
guy there bottomless charisma endless
extraversion like he's a lot about town
and he does this that knew then I
realized that I'm and this I'm the
person that the listeners have heard for
the last 170 180 episodes 300 plus hours
of me talking to also two different
people this is what I want to do I want
to nourish myself like involve my
curiosity like just satisfy my curiosity
and I would do it if no one listened
I've always liked and you feel better
now ah dude I'm I'm this is the year of
maybe not the era of transcending but
it's definitely the year of actualizing
2020 is like the year of actualizing for
me like I've never felt mental
well-being so much I've never felt so
fulfilled I feel connected to the
project I feel connected to the project
I do I'm getting yeah there's some
reward from the audience and stuff like
that but dude I do I do if no one
you know and it's it's fixing a lot of
the other things as well it's helping me
to bring other people up even outside of
the podcasting world because I don't
care about envy anymore
I'm like oh dude awesome you got a new
business that did super super well um
I'm gonna talk to this guy that
understands the neuroscience of the
seven deadly sins this evening I'll see
you later on like that's what I want to
do is you got your own stuff going on
and you're not in direct competition
yeah so looping it back to envy man
that's oh can I just say it's amazing
that I never would have thought that
love island could deliver such a
positive benefit in someone's life only
only person that was catapulted into a
life of virtue and integrity from love
Island I'll take that title look we have
a we have two deadly sins remaining we
have greed greed first it's greed seems
pretty natural yeah modern capitalist
society is it is it just a resource
acquisition gone awry what is it gone
bonkers yeah so pure greed it's pretty
nasty because for the individual this
isn't even the anti-social consequences
of it but if you think the consequences
of let's say successful greed no matter
how much you've got you want more you've
got this burning desire like you've made
a six-figure salary you want your first
million you've got a million you want
tens of million to be a billionaire like
I always think of that guy in Silicon
Valley the three comma Club I've not
watched it o'may you've got watch they
look good about their very very funny
well for a geek like me it's a very
funny comedy um but yeah it's whenever
people go up that pillar towards greater
and greater riches what's their instinct
to protect their wealth from other
people they end up in gated communities
they end up you know driving in a fat
car into an underground car park so that
they don't have to come across the
riffraff like they actively socially
distance themselves for other people
they end up socializing in in in
corridors in in in environments and
communities where no one really
likes each other they're just
competitive over who's got more money
you know like if you look at the plight
of the super-rich there is a much higher
incidence of psychological problem
psychiatric issues because they all end
up being somewhat isolated so that's
like the extreme of greed like the
absolute super-rich like you mentioned
Elon Musk earlier behind-the-scenes who
knows whether he's happy or sad but he's
saying sorry to interject they selling
out all of his possessions including all
of his houses I write everything except
for a couple of cars and what's his
explanation for that
he thinks that possessions are an attack
vector Wow interesting way of phrasing
it bro his most recent his most recent
Joe Rogan you would adore it and I'd be
really interested to hear your thoughts
about why his motivations are the way
they are the particular terminology that
he uses he's obviously a man that lives
in a world of mental models a lot and
has multidisciplinary thinking and he's
probably a [ __ ] freak Savage polymath
but has this very very particular way of
looking at the world and it sounds to me
at the moment like somebody that is on
his horn she's waiting for for a
predator to come around the corner just
a little bit um but yeah he's selling
all of his worldly possessions which
again is that's just if there was ever a
a marker in the ground of the fact that
someone's concerned about greed it's
like I'm so I'm so eaten up by the
concern of greed that I have to do the
thing that is the complete antithesis of
greed yeah right well no I mean maybe
he's just pursued the you know the world
tells us that the more material you're
advertising tells us the more material
goods you can afford that have a happier
you are look at the people you have all
the beautiful people's we hang out with
the amazing places you'll be going to
money is the best thing in the world but
like actually money look at look at your
average lottery winner they end up
falling out with everyone in their life
because everyone quite understandably
goes thinks of themselves well youth you
should not have a pot to piss in now
you've got [ __ ] load
can you lend me a grant what could you
give me a grand like you've got a
million could you give me a grand it's
not a lot of money that's not an
unreasonable proposition but the person
on the receiving end of that request is
probably gonna say to this as well well
I don't would you do that for me no hang
on wait look and it just always it
becomes about the money like if you look
at people who've been greedy and managed
to accrue lots of resources their kids
end up fighting over the inheritance
you know like families fallout over
money my name is sort of excesses of
money are crazy and then I always think
about that economic study that showed
the relationship between salary and
happiness levels but your overall
contentment with life and there is of
course there is a relationship between
income and happiness when you're low
down on the scale because if you don't
have enough money to get the basic
necessities of life a roof over your
head food in your belly being able to
live in an area where you feel safe and
secure you know if you can double your
salary which means you can move to a
better area and you can make sure that
you have good healthy food to eat you
know it will owning more money will you
know like a little modicum of greed as
always a little bit can benefit you
because it can motivate you to do more
to work harder to fight against sloth to
actually get something done and more
money and pull yourself up but beyond a
certain point this endless pursuit of
more is the antithesis of reaching a
point of contentment and satisfaction
but there's an argument that humans
aren't designed to be happy for longer
than a few minutes a few hours a few
days at a time and then we go back to
feeling just normal right no one is
perpetually happy apart from maybe that
bloat you mentioned on love Island but
yeah so pursuing
more AB infinitum doesn't make anyone
happy it can look like it from the
outside relatively but actually with
money comes responsibility
once you've got something that you could
lose then the anxiety the baggage of
[ __ ] what happens if I lose this it's
it's great I think to be slowly
incrementally on the way up but you
never want to go down again
you know that's crushing so if you I
have nothing but sympathy for people who
go from nothing to absolute vast riches
and notoriety because once you reach a
pinnacle the only way is down and you
live your whole life worrying then and
then even if you are happy you manage to
maintain it when you have a bound day
how do you explain that you've got all
the money you live in a great place
you've got you know you've bought great
things I don't know you could you deal
with the fact that you're feeling
miserable for no reason at all if you're
living a normal life then it can sit
more comfort in the acceptance of the
inevitability of sometimes feeling glum
for no particular reason it's just
easier to accept if you're not in
possession of all the things that
society tells you guarantees endless
happiness like it's just it's just
insane like I look at the people around
me like some of my mates are super-rich
self-made people some of them don't have
a pot to piss in but are doing something
with their life that they enjoy that
there is no rhyme or reason like there's
no one set one like some of them are
happy and others are hot no there's no
the richest don't make them happy the
the rich is rich people can be happy you
don't get me wrong I'm not saying that
like greed guarantees that you'll be
unhappy but greed neither guarantees nor
you know in other words towards or
against ultimately feeling content and
happy in your life beyond a certain
threshold if you're living a humble
existence but you enjoy what you do and
you feel like what you're doing is
worthwhile and it's satisfying that's
like the pot of gold
that really counts I get it man
being rich won't make you happy but
being poor can make you miserable
that's the the dichotomy that I was
taught by Morgan Housel who's a finance
expert who's been on the podcast twice
and he he identified wealth as being
able to do what you want with who you
want for as long as you want when you
want with no one being able to tell you
otherwise everything over and above that
is more money more problems as far as
I'm concerned over sloth so we're going
to learn about sloth why we why are we
lazy or apathetic is it just that we're
trying to reduce our caloric expenditure
is it just Fitness enhancing again from
our evolutionary heritage or what's
going on yeah so sloth is in moderation
is really useful if if you look at
people are overly motivated they let
their levels of stress burn so high that
they are not burning out you know and
they have they don't some people won't
stop until their bodies are literally
incapable of continuing and they make
themselves very very ill so a little bit
of laziness each day helps to sort of
clear the mind getting you ready for the
next bit a little bit of laziness each
week of the weekend having a lazy Sunday
it's good for you you need a day of rest
you know the human biology body and
brain needs to take rest we can't
pipette all that low try telling that to
a teenager or someone in their 20s like
when you've got a seemingly perpetual
energy but if you continue that kind of
ended hyper-energetic behavior through
your 30s and 40s or 50s you simply wear
yourself out earlier than you would do
otherwise it's really important to not
every time you go on holiday pack as
much in as humanly possible in terms of
stress control there is nothing better
for that in terms of doing some deep
cleaning and maintenance and repair in
your brain than having completely dull
as dishwater boring holiday boring while
cleansing boring is cleansing because if
your book said if it bought boredom is
the absence of stimulation
and stimulation requires energy to
process yep okay so what I'm saying I'm
not saying every time you go on holiday
do nothing I'm saying beware every day's
holiday you get packing as much as
humanly possible into it it's important
to give yourself downtime in the short
term day to day in the long term year to
year and there's different levels of
deep cleaning that can take place when
you take a 10 minute break before you
start another round of work in any given
day and wear one of your four weeks
holiday a year you just do nothing it's
it's it's cleansing it's good it's
healthy the extreme of sloth when you
never pull your weight what why should
you get paid the same as everyone else
if you do half the work everyone else
does back in prehistory why should you
get a fair share of the Spoils you
didn't come and hunt this food you
didn't go out gathering you do nothing
around the hat why should you obviously
these are the kind of accusations are
typically leveled at teenagers and a
teenager's brain it's halfway between
immature trial brain and a fully mature
adult brain there flip-flapping between
the two they don't count I'm talking
about adults here lazy teenagers aren't
simple that there's a reason they sleep
for hours and hours and out their brain
development needs them to sleep 10 hours
11 hours 12 hours during this all of the
parents out there yeah teenagers they
learn better if they're allowed in the
schools that allow them to start school
an hour later their scholarship goes up
not hugely but incrementally everyone
does a little bit better but yeah it's
logistically tricky to have one set of
school hours for the younger kids and
another set for the others so there's a
lot of teachers out there probably have
you read every red's why we sleep by
Matthew Walker yes I have lumber did you
see the study that he'd done in there
about the reduction in car crashes
they're done by doing the same thing
microsleeps
scared the living hell out of me I
haven't thought of that that when you're
when you have a micro sleep it might be
very very brief
like half a second but you are
completely unconscious during that time
at I had your Russian I hadn't yeah
right when the light turns red I think
I've just lost your video bro
huh you turned you play there you go it
then I white switch there you go hi
again
so yes okay sloth chilling out we need
to not have too much because then we're
getting dragged along by everybody else
but we need to ensure that we have some
I know there's a lot of people listening
that a Taipei's go-getters I'm one of
them I've had many breakdowns millions
and millions and millions of times where
I just presume that I can up regulate my
productivity and down regulate my sleep
to fit in however much work is that I
need to do and really that the only
reason that that's not seen as a device
is that the only person you end up
really hurting in that situations
yourself yeah exactly but it is whatever
so if you're supporting other people
like quite often you know the benefits
of sloth should be focused upon by those
who's sort of chief aim in life is to
help others whether it's teachers
teaching their kids or carers caring for
people or whatever supporting other
people if you don't give yourself the
opportunity to recover with a little bit
of downtime then you can't be as good a
person when you're trying to support
others whether it's in the context of a
relationship personal relationship or a
working relationship you need to get
those eight hours as often as you
possibly can in order to be the best
version of yourself when you when you
get back into the fray the following day
man Aubrey Marcus on this podcast
dropped the bomb of all bombs where he
said you do not serve others from your
cup you serve others from the saucer
which overflows around your cup right
absolutely
like knee-slapper and it's true it's
true if you don't look after self-care
you can't be everything that you need to
be to those around you
same reason why when you're in a plane
crash when you have the oxygen
decompression that's before you don't
want them before you try and help
someone else because if you're
suffocating you're of no use to anyone
else
final thing final round Roth is it the
most immediately damaging sin that we've
got yeah immediately damaging and I
suppose it is and we're all into again
modicum of Roth we're all entitled to
feel angry
it's a perfectly ways a modicum of Roth
why is a modicum good well as in if
every time you get angry frustrated you
feel that aggression you beat yourself
up for doing it like that's that's
that's not that's not right so for
example if other people are taking
advantage of you physically mentally you
have a right to verbally push them back
if they're being physically abusive you
know is is embedded in the law the an
eye for an eye is all about your your
come back if someone attacks you your
comeback needs to be equivalent you know
you can't go if someone prods you on the
shoulder you can't punch him in the face
if someone punches you in the face you
can't shoot them with a gun that's all
at all I for an I means right I'm it's
about whatever whatever ill has been
done towards you you need to be measured
in your response you can't be
disproportionate in your response if you
are you're going to go to prison if
you're proportionate in your response
then you might not go to prison you know
I mean like in the case of a violent
conflict so we all have a right to get
angry with other people when they're
mocking us about but we don't have a
right or or taught to physically repel
people who are physically aggravating us
within reason we have a right to do that
it's just when aggression is given free
rein obviously like big drunk guy coming
and harassing me at speakers corner like
he was aggressively abusing me and I had
a right to thirdly abuse him back I
wasn't proud of it because I was trying
not to but I had a right to do that
because you you know verbal its basic
aggression can be a like a verbal
physical discouragement from further
aggravation but but when it's that the
problem is again it just going back to
that dACC area the dorsal anterior
cingulate cortex
I love the study that showed this brain
area kicking in in the context of Roth
because they got people wired up with
electrodes so that they could deliver
electric shocks to each other inside the
scanner they put a dial and they can
crank up the voltage of how much pain
med delivering through that electric
shock and they found that in a
tit-for-tat exchange where one person's
actually get out her I mean he's a
composer
wow that was much harder than the one I
gave you you know you go it escalates as
it always does and these two tit for tat
retaliation up and up and up and up and
up they found that the dACC brain area
kicks in in a manner that was positively
correlated to how much they cranked up
that voltage so the feeling of inner
term or of pain drove the amount of
revenge they wanted to get and it's when
you kind of get into the realms of
people fantasizing about the retribution
that they're going to take the revenge
they're going to exact to punish someone
for a perceived wrongdoing that's when
it starts getting thought that's when
people start getting murdered that's
when people start you know that maybe an
individual maybe loads of them and it
doesn't even have to be causing another
person's death it could just be causing
horrible traumatic injury to someone
else on the basis sometimes it just you
know wounded pride all of us have been
in that situation man that in my least
gracious moments you know when you think
about what you would have said or could
have said or would have died right well
if he if there's a man like and the
cathartic pleasure that you take from
imagining the thing like dude there's
facebook debates from a decade ago that
I still rule not writing the response
that I think I should have said at least
you honored that particular guidance
maybe I think I might have just not had
had enough caffeine in me so I couldn't
reach the level of like vitriol that I
was trying to get it was what about I
was restricted by my blood caffeine
content rather than by virtue I couldn't
believe this just that he dropped ninety
percent of all murders
are committed by men does this show that
most aggression is biologically rooted
rather than socialized it's impossible
to know for sure because boys are
socialized different to girls
there you go but like you know and there
are conditions where females have you
know very very very high levels of
testosterone for other reason like women
have testosterone too right it's just
that men produce this extra payload in
their gonads so some women can
biologically produce an equivalent of a
male level of terror and they are as
aggressive as men are typically Sirhan's
the aggression drug then yeah so
testosterone drives the bodily changes
of male sexual characteristics but it's
also involved certainly in aggression
it's just it's a bit tricky because if
you like one study they did was looking
at people who were taking testosterone
as an anabolic steroid and you know were
they more aggressive than others and it
it's just never a clear-cut answer it
would be really nice to go yeah
testosterones to blame but testosterone
maybe promotes aggression but then there
are other brain areas that can rein it
in to more reasonable levels and so it's
always an interplay between the drive
building up becoming greater and greater
and then other brain areas that are
putting the brakes on those fundamental
drives and is it because there's too
much Drive or is it because there's too
much lack of the ability to apply the
brakes and it's just not as clear-cut as
you'd like one study you'll say yeah
it's all about the testosterone that
makes men so aggressive and then other
studies are going that it's gonna have
to do the testosterone it's something
else entirely so it's just hard to give
a clear-cut explanation
that's an interest in one man right my
final question to you Joe haven't
prepped you for so sorry about this is
is there something missing from the
seven deadly sins and if there is what
do you think would rank at number eight
or perhaps what could be a contender
Wow to add in there did you consider
this no no I was because I was happy to
learn from ancient wisdom I didn't
really like reading the same science had
actually tallied with with with the
religious kind of beliefs the community
mix I was hoping for it but it wasn't
banking on it though I didn't really I
didn't really go beyond I was thinking
what can people do with this um if there
was
you
Oh Who am I to go beyond the greatest
thinkers of of you know mankind's
history because it's not just
Christianity that came up with these
seven things so many other religions
have pointed the finger at pride
excessive pride excessive aggression
excessive Envy it's just these are
universally recognized as antisocial
forces so is there an eight antisocial
force that isn't captured by them I'm
just asking you to try and undo 3,000
years of work and then perhaps build on
it in the space of 15 the problem is I
reckon anything I say you'd be able to
argue that it's a combination of those
seven almost axiomatic slightly
problematic tribes because I was
thinking along the lines of now we've
got this new player technology you know
this overconsumption of technology is in
play and like like a gluttony of
information almost yeah and also there's
so much so for example that there's a
few things on that topic that are
pertinent here like if you know that the
information you've just looked up is up
there on the internet and you can go
back and look at any time you won't
remember what what you read a day later
like people's memories are rubbish we
don't retain information anymore because
of the context where we know we can just
look it up I think how many
conversations are ruined by everyone
like you know I wonder if the other day
it used to be that you can spend half an
hour discussing that the likelihood of
whether it's this or that or what is the
explanation for that you know why do
they call it a pot to piss in
you can spend ages trying to work it out
now you just go online and go oh it's
because people used to sell there we if
they were really poor and if you didn't
have a pot you couldn't even sell your
urine you know like you just you can
just look it up now but then quite often
people look at her and then a month
later the same thing comes up oh yeah I
knew the answer to that and they can't
remember what which I don't think is
good for the individual or for the
masses it's things like if you people
that are always looking at their phone
they're not so good at empathy
like any task that involves empathy if
you're not looking at someone's face and
body language you're not really
absorbing the cues that are emanating
from them that give you the subtext of
how they're really feeling about what's
being discussed if everyone's head down
looking at their screen they are by
definition not looking at other people's
faces and you need to look at people in
order to take in that body language to
run it through the empathy circuits so
there's a bit this is all early evidence
but I feel like the seventh the eighth
deadly sin would be along the lines of
technology delivers clear benefits you
know labor-saving enlightening you know
this technology your listeners you are
using technology to communicate with me
across the vast Europe and Newcastle
right across the length of a country
opposite ends of a country and then and
then you're packaging it and then your
digital eats tree you know giving it to
people all over the world without
technology our knowledge would be vastly
vastly limited but to like a
ill-disciplined consumption of
Technology never asking yourself how
much is too much of what is social media
on average making me happier after I've
used it or sadder am I starting to feel
less motor very much am i starting to
feel deflated every time I look at it
because it's such a source of envy
malicious negative Envy because
everyone's falsely showing their their
showreel of the best things in their
life and completely ignoring the
negatives creating this false perception
of how great everyone else's lives are
compared to our own so so yeah
the excessive use of technology to the
detriment of your of the interests of
your well being that's the new gateway
that would be my eighth deadly sin of
the modern age I think that's a really
good shout man and whatever the I'm
trying to think of the word that is the
opposite of boredom or a fear of boredom
a fear of being alone without the input
of other Minds or information
I mean they think it's bad I don't want
to leave I don't want to leave your
listeners with the idea that boredom is
bad
boredom is great oh dude because because
into the boredom into continuous boredom
the human brain hates it and into that
vacuum crazy ideas but like the crazy
positively like eccentric unusual things
the notions about what might be fun to
do to ease that boredom like without
boredom a lot of the greatest human
strokes of insight would never have come
because you need to quieten a mind
sufficiently to hear those ideas
bubbling up from your subconscious brain
processes if you're constantly consuming
stuff you're never you're never quiet
earning your brain enough to hear what's
what's gently bubbling up to the surface
of your consciousness because there's
music and conversation and you know like
internet and TV and films and
consumption Netflix tip five four three
two one next second tip next episode
next episode just give in give in to the
torrent mode switch it off for a whole
day bore yourself to death and then see
what emerges see what weird things you
decide to go and do not all of which
will be great but a few of them will
change your life so sorry be on tipper
sister boredom I would say is being
incredibly stimulated by the outside
world and a desire for that is perhaps
somewhere in amongst this new 8th sindh
that we've got look Jack man we thanks
man you helped me have an original
thought maybe we did we did a thing me
and you did a thing and if you do a
sequel and it's the the eighths in um
imma do you know like how Robert Greene
did that like the 50th law and and 50
cent came in and it was just like purely
all Robert Greene and then 50 Cent's
just like yo what's up in the club and
then I think that's me I'm the I'm the
guy that just gets his name on the book
cuz because I'm a famous rapper but tell
us tell the listeners YouTube channel
Twitter where where do they go link to
buy the science of sin I highly
recommend that you go and get it really
cool
there's
so much stuff that we didn't go into and
it will be available in the show notes
below via Amazon and all other
booksellers but what else we're on
Twitter at the yard Jack Lewis at dr.
Jack Lewis
well so my web site
www.kpbs.org/news/evening edition
[Music]
I think that virtual reality has even
though it's been around 40 years it
hasn't even scratched the surface of its
potential and I think virtuality is so
good I spent half the time in my in my
youtube channel saying don't overdo it
this has got such huge potential to be
addictive but I don't want you to lose
interest in the real world because when
I first started doing it right some
people when they DVR'd they don't use a
good headset and they write off the are
saying it's not as you know piped up
it's rubbish I've only used an oculus go
write rubbish when you use a high-end
one the experiences that can be offered
are so different what's the what's the
spec of whatever you're rolling with at
the moment I got before they even
launched it I bought myself an HTC vive
so much so it's it's almost obsolete now
I've had it for four years but it's one
of these ones where you're tethered to a
powerful graphics PC you know you need
that graphics power to update what your
eyes are seeing enough so that when you
look around it shows your eyes exactly
what you would see if you were in that
virtual world but the thing is it's like
it transcends
games and experiences and documentary
and like it's and it's only limited by
human imagination but every day I think
when kovat happened
I turned beat Sabre where you're sort of
slashing
using lightsabers to hit boxes that
flight me through the air I made my own
version
called covitz Lasher and it was like in
the week that they saw what covertly
released an image of what cove had
looked like I modeled it and had it so
that you're cutting in half all these
covered viruses are coming towards you
from all directions and it was sort of
it was so cathartic because there was
nothing else to do he felt a bit
helpless like what can you do there's
nothing you can do you just have to wait
for scientists to do their wonderful
work over the course of years and make
the bloody vaccine um and in the
meantime you might as well just get your
frustration out it was some covert I
woke up in the morning with a crazy idea
cuz I was bored
and by the morning of the next day I've
made it it's a virtual world that you'll
bono inhabit yeah and that's just
copying other people's games like those
are things that you can do in VR which
are basically taking a concept that's
been done over and over again in other
world in other media with a flat-screen
computer gaming or cinema or whatever
and then just redoing in a 3d
environment it's rubbish there's loads
of stuff that you can do that completely
unique to VR that you can only do in VR
and so that's why I'm sort of well
ultimately one that there's build VR
things which are really fun games to
play but secretly I mean your listeners
will know you know and I know but I'm
not going to advertise it in the
background it's going to be improving
your cognitive capabilities because
there's so many games out there that
people pull up loads of time into that
has no potential to improve their brain
power and and it's just the matter of
designing the game right to actually
improve people's attention working
memory decision-making multitasking
capabilities blablabla I'm just going to
have it all built in and then the dream
is measure people's capacities covertly
as they start playing again measure them
again a year a month later a year later
hopefully they'll keep playing keep
playing and then just show them
retrospectively your working memory is
improved by four or five points your
attention span is increased from 30
seconds to you know like and just show
them it's good thing played this game
because now your brains bare bro that's
the dream that is so cool I mean the
oculus go that I got was often ex-missus
and then we split
and I sold it so there's no danger of me
going back to one that's that's super
lame but that sounds that sounds awesome
I don't know whether you know Paul
Stamets a guy that does a lot of stuff
into like mice
mycology he's like a big mushroom
supplementation also psychedelics but
not just that like lion's mane and all
manner of mad [ __ ] and he did a similar
thing with a dosing micro dosing
protocol and you were to do take an app
and do like finger tapping the speed of
your finger tapping and other other
other like micro movements and other
bits and pieces and they tracked it
through this quantified self app so
that's kind of like a more upfront
version and probably a lot less fun like
just tap in a way although micro dose it
micro dosing and then going into VR I
mean that's I've no one needs to do that
there's enough it's funny you should say
that because like I'm super excited I
finally got its out that I listened to a
podcast that talks a lot about latest
developments in VR and this bloke in
some cabin in the middle of nowhere in
Canada spent the last six years creating
what he calls a techno bellick it's a VR
experience that can simulate a
psychedelic experience with the idea
that psychedelic experiences sometimes
can go badly but quite often can give
people new fresh perspectives on things
in their life that that they maintain
that healthier perspective long after
the drug has left their system you know
and he wants to create the same thing
using using light and sound and to try
and simulate those trippy experiences in
order to hopefully give people the
positive impacts on their well-being but
without the danger over there so I'm
literally gonna get stuck into that as
soon as I get off here and then I'll
report back I look forward to it look
Jack man this is one of the longest
episodes I've done in a while but I've
absolutely loved it and there's still so
much that I could go into so having met
you I'm now gonna listen to your
podcasts uh-huh dude well if you notice
the fact that the camera angle doesn't
change but that we swap t-shirts between
episode lifehacks 101 and life actual
two then you'll know exactly now and so
so does everyone else look listen like
share and subscribe you already know
what to do all the links to everything
that we've gone through Jack's cool
YouTube channel where he does stuff on
VR and the book the fantastic science of
sin will be linked below
but for now Jack man thank you so much
it's amazing
[Music]